thanks for joining us America here in
the lobby of financial peace Plaza
Justin and Tara are with us hey guys how
are you good thank you
welcome welcome where do you guys live
Edwardsburg Michigan okay which is near
what South Bend Indiana South Bend
Indiana yes perfect and you're here to
do a debt-free scream I assume yes yeah
excellent how much have you paid off we
paid off one hundred and fifty thousand
and forty three months way to go
making what kind of money we started at
80,000 and we moved up to 130 Wow how'd
you do that
hard work and I was blessed to get a
better paying job and worked for a
really good company so Wow awesome nice
promotions then yes Stefan what do you
do for a living I'm a director of an
assisted living community oh okay very
fun nurse that Hospital home where else
oh great
very good took great careers very good
so what kind of debt was the hundred and
fifty thousand strictly your mortgage
you paid off your house how old are you
guys we were twenty eighth time we
actually paid it off on Black Friday
last year hey very cool
house and everything is paid off baby
step seven yeah man that's amazing and
not now what's the house worth it was
appraised at 265 wow that's pretty cool
and you own it has that snow yes i but
we still went outside and found a patch
of green spots took your shoes off in
this land so a hundred and fifty
thousand paid off in 43 months that's
house and everything what made you think
you could or should do this well we
actually read the Total Money Makeover
blessed to receive it actually as a
college graduation gift in January of oh
wait and at that time was perfect
because we're getting out of college
we're thinking well we deserve a new
house new cars all those things we read
that and where they go we don't we can't
afford this enough we think we deserve
and so it kind of brought us back down
kept us focused we actually were blessed
to then live with her grandma for a year
live in some cheap apartments and we're
actually able to build our house oh and
during the building process actually a
funny point was we had some of thefts
from the site and so my parents I have a
horse farm and they had a horse trailer
with living quarters that were actually
at a park next to the site and we lived
in it for four months to get we're
building to their site pletely camping
out it's 38 degrees inside that's scary
you guys are on the top I'm not a
southern boy that's not those TV trays
up in the bed where the blanket warmer
was just makes it so much worth it you
know yeah now you're sitting there with
almost a $300,000 paid for house and
you're not 30 that's right you paid a
price to win didn't the people make fun
of you they had to I mean come on they
had they call your horse trailer they do
yeah yeah we had so much support amazing
family and friends and work families and
we have a lot of cheerleaders so that's
cool yeah yeah so people believed in
your dreams
we were pretty persistent about saying
our goals out loud and and to anybody
really we talked about you we buy your
books and give them out to everybody
that we know 20 yeah thank you if we
talked anybody in they guilty with you
living in a horse trailer you live in a
nice people house now you know life's
good yeah oh man that's just great you
guys I'm so proud of you you're great
man you guys are the future yeah are you
making a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars a year you know a payment in the
world on a house payment not anything
this is gonna be the math on this is
staggering and you're not even 30 oh my
gosh you talk about change your family
tree but the amount of giving you're
gonna be able to do is just astronomical
it is you're amazing very very cool you
too so what do you tell people the key
is I ask almost four for me it's really
just team work I couldn't imagine if we
weren't on the same page of doing the
things that we did we have
conversations about it in we would set
the goal and we're both so competitive
that once we set the goal we're going
for it and so it was awesome to have her
on board with me yeah so Tara what do
you think the key was I think it was
goal-setting as well seeing those goals
out loud to kind of hold ourselves
accountable for those goals and then I
won't you brag about it you got a do
everybody kind of looks at you like yeah
good luck with that
mortgage it was like that they were
trying to talk us into a thirty year
then and we said no over into a 15 and
we're gonna pay this off even faster
than that
we're like okay sure so I had a call in
my queue it was awesome yeah we threw
your Dave out more than are your name
out more than our first year when
anybody we're at JC Penney's you need a
card Dave Ramsey would be really mad at
you I personally would call funny you
guys are great all right guys I love it
Justin and Tara the house and everything
is paid off let's get the kiddos in here
how old are the kids Gracie is three and
Fletcher is 18 months oh my goodness
we're ready this is a great young family
what a great story you guys are
beautiful that's amazing all right here
we go
I love it a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars paid off in 43 months making 80
thousand now making a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars a year count it down
house and everything
let's hear a debt free scream
I love it well done you guys well done
well done well done
oh man that spot Wow they are young for
a paid-for house guys this is getting
better and better and better and man all
three today only have come in the
building and they're all young young
families now old people are getting out
of debt too by the way like me but these
young families guys that's the future
right there they don't owe anyone almost
a $300,000 house that rocks
you